la población en general y diferentes
partidos políticos incluidos el
conservador del que boris johnson es el
jefe han criticado la decisión de
terminar su presencia en afganistán tras
20 años porque la han considerado un
fracaso pero también critican la crisis
que se ha generado en medio de esta
evacuación humanitaria está la molestia
en el parlamento británico que
recordemos la semana pasada fue
convocado de manera urgente
extraordinaria en medio de las
vacaciones del verano para una sesión
especial sobre afganistán que contempla
la posibilidad de crear una comisión
independiente para investigar qué hizo
el reino unido- en los 20 años de
ocupación en afganistán y por supuesto
toda esta crisis derivada de las
evacuaciones humanitarias una de las
posturas que más ha llamado la atención
y una de las más tristes ha sido la del
jefe del comité de relaciones exteriores
del parlamento toma tan en jan quien
también hizo parte de las tropas
británicas en afganistán y ha dicho que
ha sido la mayor crisis de rehenes que
el reino unido ha visto y ha lamentado
por supuesto que los afganos que
sirvieron por tantos como traductores de
las tropas británicas en terreno afgano
no hayan podido ser vacado se cree que
un número aún indeterminado entre 800 y
1500 afganos no podrán salir de ese país
lamentable luisa ahora el g7 que
actualmente preside reinó unido- incidió
en la necesidad de permitir vacaciones
más allá del 31 de agosto que esfuerzos
realiza londres entonces para que más
personas puedan abandonar afganistán más
allá más allá de esta fecha
preparando al país para la crudeza de
este momento en medio de la crisis
humanitaria que se vive en ese país el
ministro de defensa- ben wallace había
dicho que no todas las personas podrían
ser evacuadas por ello el reino unido-
ha pedido especialmente a los afganos
que traten de llegar a terceros países
como irán o pakistán para en esos
terceros países poder procesar todos los
documentos necesarios de quienes son
elegibles para venir a este país sin
embargo recordemos el talibán ya ha
dicho que no permitirá que nadie más
salga de su país por lo menos los
afganos por supuesto los medios locales
están llenos de historias desgarradoras
de intérpretes de las tropas británicas
que no podrán salir del país uno de
ellos dijo hoy estar escondido por temor
a que el talibán lo identifique lo
identifique y pueda ser asesinado además
dijo que no tiene los recursos para
salir del país como lo ha pedido el
gobierno por sus propios medios